[Music]
you might love shopping but shopping
doesn't love you that's because whenever
you think that you saw a great deal the
store is actually tricking you if you
ever bought something that you don't
need you'll have to watch this video
stay tuned until the end to see while
sales are not as good as you thought
they were if you love shopping as much
as we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you 10 ways stores
are trying to fool you the dress sizes
we've all been there we think that we
wear small and then we go to another
store and it doesn't fit so we have to
take a medium it makes us believe that
we ate too many tacos but then in the
next door we are wearing extra small and
it just gets worse with jeans but why is
this happening to us our body can't
suddenly change from one store to
another but don't worry you're not the
problem it's the stores the reason why
designers are telling you that you
should wear an extra small shirt is what
they want to make you feel better
no one likes to find out that they're
wearing a larger size after not shopping
for months making you believe that you
now fit in the next all will make you
feel better about your bodies the best
actually just a trick the difference can
even be up to eight and a half inches
for a pair of jeans of the same size and
these numbers change drastically over
the years if you want to find the store
that you can trust look at the
standardized sizes in your country and
find the store that really knows that
you are supposed to wear according to
your measurements when you think that
they are just being honest with you we
will feel much more comfortable in a
larger shirt ok guys we are so excited
to announce we're producing our own
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIYs fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it and be sure to
let us know what you think in the
comment section
hey lefty here from you see you there
the lights have you ever been in the
changing room and just felt terrible do
you think that you just found an amazing
outfit and then you just look like a fat
potato when you look at yourself in the
mirror it's happened to every one of us
but the problem is not you or your style
the lighting is simply not the same in
every store and some of them don't know
how to make you feel confident however
those who know how to make you shine can
easily trick you into buying all the
clothes that you wanted to try in the
changing room some women visited many
different dressing rooms in different
stores with the same outfit and you can
clearly see that they don't look the
same at all as you can see we just hate
shadows but we're not totally against
looking a little Tanner harsh overhead
lighting doesn't look good on anyone but
vertical lights on either side of the
mirror are much better for everyone
well if you go to a store where the
lighting looks as good as this it might
actually be bad for you that's because
you might end up buying more clothes and
you're supposed to just focus on this
boost of confidence and you'll forget
that you bought a beautiful dress that
you'll never have the opportunity to
wear the layouts we know it's time to go
to the grocery store when we have to buy
milk and store owners know that this is
why they make sure that it's as far as
possible from the entrance and this is
why you'll have to look at all the
delicious things around you and in to
find $80 worth of food will you just
learn to put something in your cereal
however some people argue that grocery
stores are not really that means milk
just needs to be refrigerated right away
and the reason why is that the fact that
the store is where the trucks unload
their fridges are there so they can fill
the cases as quick as possible but you
can see this trick in clothing stores -
cells are at the back so you have to
look at all the other beautiful clothes
even though you were trying to save
money we know that it works because we
all fell for it and if you are strong
and think that you didn't you know that
you did buy Keeney's or accessories at
least once in your life when you were
waiting
mind to pay you just have nothing to do
and these beautiful candies are there
looking at you telling you to treat
yourself a little bit after this long
trip to the store it's not your fault
the stores are just trying to fool you
the shelves when you think about it you
don't have to bend down that much when
you go to a store you know that there
are things at the bottom of the shelves
but it just looks like they're meant to
stay there as no one is even looking at
them and this is exactly what is
supposed to happen in the store anything
the store really wants customers to buy
will always be at eye level that's why
it is never hard to find your favorite
brand as it is popular if it's at the
end of the aisle it's even better it
will get even more attention but don't
think that this is making the items
better that's because the most expensive
items are also the ones at eye level
it's the first thing that you see and
stores expect that you won't take the
time to bend down to look at the items
at the bottom of the shelves it could
save you some money but it looks like
many people think that it's not worth
the effort and stores really saw that
coming when they decided to use this
little trick to their advantage next
time you go to a store try to look down
a little bit and see what you could find
the prices have you ever thought that
it's clear to see that an item is $19.99
why can't you ever sins and make it $20
we'd love to round numbers if you're in
Canada it's even more stupid because you
don't even use pennies anymore do the
stores really think that we should be
happy because we are saving one penny
it's not about that at all you should
never think that stores are actually
doing something to help you the reason
why this nice shirt is $19.99 is that
they hope that you will just look at the
first number and think that the shirt is
only $19 when it's actually $20 it makes
us feel dumb but we are a little
disappointed when we think is amusing
doing this is that it works but we found
out about a trick that's even worse
let's say you can buy a $500 phone or
$1000 phone and both are really similar
you'll buy the cheapest one right but
when you think about it 500 dollars is
actually already really expensive that's
why the stores are also selling a
thousand dollar phone they know that
they are not going to sell a lot of them
but this is not the point they are just
using it to make you feel like the $500
phone is not that expensive we fell for
this trick to this sizes we already
talked about clothes sizes but did you
know that the size of the new object to
have an influence on you when you enter
the store one of the first things you
see is shopping carts now you are
probably wondering how they can mess up
with our brains with something so simple
but did you notice that they got bigger
over the years they remain to make a
larger purchases more easily but they
actually have a bad influence when you
are not looking for a lot of things
that's because when you have a big cart
you will feel the need to fill it with
fangers that you don't even need the
bigger the cart is the more purchases
you made so you better go for a little
hand basket instead and when it comes to
food you shouldn't think that the stores
your friends when they can you the
choice to buy larger products for
example let's say you used to buy a
six-pack of soda every week and drink
all of them if the new option now is a
12-pack of soda
you'll start buying that and think that
it will last two weeks but what will
happen is that you are probably going to
change your habits and drink those
twelve soda cans in one week and this is
how this daily change can end up you
know
the expensive habit the atmosphere we
all love going to a clothing store and
dancing to the beat of the music or go
into the grocery store and smelling all
the delicious food but do you know that
all of this might be playing against you
the music is like the soundtrack of our
life and it's making us feel different
things if the music is slow you will
take more time to walk around the store
and look at everything if the music has
more rhythm it's probably just to make
you feel more confident if you want to
spend less money at a store put on some
headphones and listen to your own music
the smell can also have a big influence
on you if you smell food as soon as you
enter the grocery store you will
suddenly feel more hungry and we all
know that it's a bad idea to go to the
grocery store when you are hungry
because it makes us buy too many things
but why do you find fruits and
vegetables as soon as you into the
grocery store after all they don't
really smell that's actually because the
bright colors will get your attention
and you will feel the need to buy more
things
the deals if you think that you finally
found a great deal think again the
stores will do whatever they can to earn
more money so they are certainly not
giving something away just so that you
can treat yourself first don't think
that you'll get a better deal by buying
in bulk you're actually not saving as
much money as you think you are
sometimes you'll only save a couple of
cents
to buying the same number of things
separately you might think that you are
saving money but not when you are buying
more things than you really wanted to
what is worse is that sometimes vine and
bulk actually makes you lose money it
would be cheaper if you bought all these
things individually the 10 for $10 is
also one of the best ways to make you
buy many more things than you are
supposed to even if you are not
interested in this at all if you want to
find a good sale at the supermarket you
need to look at something that is half
the price and we are not talking about
buy one get the second 50% off when you
think about it these two things together
we're only 25% off you really need to
pay attention to the deals that the
stores offer because most of the time
they are the only ones who are winning
the dollar signs sometimes the trick is
so simple that it's really hard to see
it but we can tell you that it's always
there look at these two price tags and
try to find the difference everything
looks the same except for one thing the
dollar sign is missing on the second
price tag and this is why more people
might be tempted to buy it you might
think that we don't need a dollar sign
to understand that this number is
actually the price that we want to buy
but it has more influence than what you
might think that's because a dollar sign
is associated with paying for something
when you can only see the price it makes
you think that this is simply what the
shirt is worth and what you can earn if
you buy it a symbol of gain replaces a
symbol of cost and customers suddenly
start buying more things it's a really
subtle subliminal message but if the
stores keep doing it this is probably
because they already saw it works
restaurants do that a lot when you can't
see the dollar sign all you can think
about is all the delicious things on the
menu if we were store owners we think
that it would absolutely be worth a try
the sales is there anything that we
can't love about sells
we are going to show you that there are
that's because most of the sales are not
really different than the regular price
if you look at the original price you'll
probably see that you are only saving a
dollar or even just a quarter sometimes
the original and the new prices are
actually the same when you see an
article look 50% off that doesn't mean
that it was a good deal maybe it cost
$20 but then they made it cost $40 just
to lower it down to $20 again and
pretend that there is a sale some of the
most popular stores can also just
clearly lie for example you see a new
price tag over an old one but if you
look under the new price tag you'll see
that it was even less expensive before
if they keep telling you that the sell
will only last for a few days this is
also a warning sign they just want to
make you buy that item right now without
thinking about it and it doesn't happen
only in some weird little shops but also
in some of the most popular stores in
the world can you think of any other way
the stores are trying to fool you don't
be shy to tell us what you think in the
comment section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for 10
Way stores are trying to fool you for
more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 tips to spot fake products
thanks for watching
[Music]